[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Dana: WELCOME BACK TO
HOLLYWOOD, FLORIDA, THE
OUT-OF-CONTROL PRICES AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER IS LEADING
PEOPLE TO TAKE DRASTIC MEASURES,
FAMILY IS LIVING NEAR THE BORDER
IN YUMA, ARIZONA, FORCED TO HIRE
ARMED PRIVATE SECURITY GUARDS
BECAUSE OF AN ARM SURGE THAT HAS
BEEN FEARING FOR THEIR SAFETY.
IN SOME CASES THE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS HAVE BEEN WALKING
RIGHT ONTO THEIR PROPERTY AND
EVEN INTO THEIR HOMES.
AND THE FLOOD OF MIGRANTS IT
SAID TO GET WORSE, AND ALLOWED
THE U.S. TO IMMEDIATELY
REPORT -- DEPORT MIGRANTS TO
BORDER DEMOCRATS SAYING THAT HIS
PARTY NEEDS TO WISE UP FAST ON
THE ISSUE.
>> IS THOUGH BORDER OPEN,
DEFINITELY, ABSOLUTELY, IT IS
OPEN.
AND POLICY HAS TO CHANGE.
AND IF YOU DON'T CHANGE THE
POLICIES, YOU WON'T MAKE A
DIFFERENCE AT THE BORDER.
AND HAVE ALWAYS BEEN VERY STRONG
ON BORDER SECURITY.
>> Dana: GREG ABBOTT SENDING
ANOTHER BUS, TO DEMOCRAT LED
PHILADELPHIA, THE CITIES LIBERAL
DISTRICT TELLING HIM HIS MOVE
COULD BE A CRIME AND BLASTED IT
AS IRRESPONSIBLE, LATE DISREGARD
FOR HUMAN LIVES WHICH IS WHY I
WANT TO GO TO YOU FIRST, JUDGE.
IF AN ACTUAL CRIME, AND IT WAS
ILLEGAL, WOULD'VE BEEN STOPPED
BEFORE BECAUSE THESE MIGRANT
BUSES HAVE BEEN COMING?
>> Judge Jeanine: THE LOCAL
D.A. WHO IS A PROGRESSIVE AND A
SOROS GUY.
IF HE THINKS THEY ARE SENDING
THE STATE CRIME WHICH ONLY THE
D.A. HAS JURISDICTION, JOE BIDEN
LETTING THEM IN AS A FEDERAL
CRIME FROM THEIR COUNTRY TO THE
UNITED STATES.
OKAY, WHAT'S GOOD FOR THE GOOSE
IS GOOD FOR THE GANDER.
NOW THERE IS A SECOND THING, THE
DISTRICT JUDGE WHO DECIDED IN
WASHINGTON THAT HE WOULD CANCEL
42 WHICH ALLOWS US TO SEND THEM
RIGHT BACK RIGHT AWAY, I DON'T
KNOW WHY WE SAY THAT, BECAUSE
3 MILLION OF THEM ARE MARCHING
IN.
I DON'T KNOW WHO WE ARE SENDING
BACK, HAROLD WILL TELL YOU.
IN THE END --
>> Harold: MY FRIEND.
>> Judge Jeanine: YES, MY
FRIEND HAROLD, THEY ARE COMING
IN A PEOPLE ARE HIRING SECURITY
FOR THEMSELVES IS A VERY
DANGEROUS SITUATION.
AND WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
ABLE TO PROTECT THEMSELVES, AND
IN ANY SEGMENT OF 3 MILLION
PEOPLE COMING INTO THE
UNITED STATES, I WOULD WANT TO
KNOW WHO IS A CRIMINAL, WHO IS
A, WHO WAS A DRUNK, WHO BEATS
HIS WIFE?
WHO IS AN IDENTITY THIEF, WHO IS
A RAPIST AND ON AND ON.
AND LET'S NOT KID OURSELVES,
THIS IS AN INVASION LED BY
GENERAL SULLIVAN WHO IS THE
JUDGE IN D.C. AND REFUSED TO
ALLOW BILL BARR TO DROP THE
CHARGES AGAINST MICHAEL FLYNN.
OKAY, HE IS VERY MUCH A LEFTIST
JUDGE.
>> Greg: DANA, YOU GUYS ARE
MISSING THE POINT, WHEN HE SAID
IT WAS AGAINST THE LAW OR A
CRIMINAL DESCENDANT TO BUS LISTS
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT BUSTING THEM TO
PHILLY, WHICH IS --
>> Dana: HAVE YOU SEEN WHAT IS
HAPPENING?
>> Greg: IT IS CRUEL AND
UNUSUAL PUNISHMENT TO SEND
ANYBODY TO PHILADELPHIA, AS MUCH
AS IT CAN'T STAND ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION, NO ONE DESERVES
THAT.
I WOULD NOT EVEN SEND HAROLD TO
PHILLY.
>> Harold: I WENT TO COLLEGE
IN PHILLY.
>> Judge Jeanine: HE WENT TO
PENN.
>> Harold: I'M SAYING GERALDO
BECAUSE I WENT TO PENN.
>> Judge Jeanine: HE IS AN
IVY LEAGUE OR.
>> Greg: WHICH SCHOOL?
>> Judge Jeanine: PENN.
>> Greg: THAT IS NOT AN
IVY LEAGUE SCHOOL.
>> Jesse: WHERE DID YOU GO
AGAIN, GREG?
>> Greg: BERKELEY.
BUT THESE BUSES SHOOK THE BOX OF
IMMIGRATION, IMMIGRATION HAS
BEEN DOING THE SAME THING YEAR
AFTER YEAR, AND IF YOU LIKE
CHEAP LABOR, THEN YOU'RE SHARING
THE WEALTH.
AND YOU SHOULD BE GOING, PLEASE
COME HERE, I'M MISSING SWEAR
CITY, IF YOU DON'T LIKE IT, YOU
ARE GOING, THIS IS GREAT BECAUSE
WE ARE SHARING THE BURDEN.
SO THAT'S WHAT THEY HAVE TO
CONTINUE DOING, THEY HAVE TO
TRIPLE IT AND EXPONENTIALLY JUST
DO IT BECAUSE THEN YOU WILL GET
EVERYBODY, EVERY STATE BECOMES A
BORDER STATE, AND THAT'S WHEN
ACTION TAKES PLACE.
>> Dana: DON'T YOU HERE IN
FLORIDA FEEL LIKE YOU ARE A
BORDER STATE?
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION PROBLEM AS
WELL, AND WOULD YOU LIKE TO
ANSWER AS TO WHO WE ARE SENDING
BACK?
>> Harold: YOU KNOW, I HAVE
BEEN A PROPONENT IN FAIRNESS,
AND THE FOUR OF YOU, I'VE BEEN A
PROPONENT AND CRITICIZED BY MY
OWN PARTY BECAUSE I THINK WE
SHOULD BUILD A WALL.
I THINK --
BUT AT THE SAME TIME, WE HAVE TO
MAKE THIS UNCOMFORTABLE FOR
EVERYONE, THERE ARE REPUBLICANS
WHO DON'T BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD
INVEST IN A SMART WAY IMPARTS,
WE SPEND TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS
AND HAVE AS A NATION TO
STABILIZE AND TRY TO BRING PEACE
TO AREAS OF THE WORLD AND EAT IT
BUT IN OUR OWN BACKYARD WE SPEND
PENNIES AND WE WONDER WHY WE
HAVE THIS, I'M NOT SAYING OUR
DOLLARS CAN SOLVE THE PROBLEMS,
BUT WE NEED TO BE MORE
THOUGHTFUL AND COORDINATED AND
HOW WE DO IT.
WE HAVE TO PERFORM THIS ASYLUM
PROCESS.
GREG TALKED ABOUT THIS
ELOQUENTLY AND HAS FOR A WHILE
ABOUT WE NEED WORKERS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
AND WE NEED NOT ONLY AMERICAN
WORKERS, BUT WORKERS FROM
OUTSIDE THE COUNTRY AND THERE
HAS TO BE A PROCESS TO HELP DO
THIS.
>> Greg: SOMEBODY NEEDS TO
CHOP JESSE'S.
>> Jesse: THAT DOES NOT SOUND
VERY NICE.
>> Dana: AND IF YOU DID NOT
SEE THE A BLOCK IT, HAS CONTEXT.
>> Harold: I HAVE TO FINISH MY
CONTEXT, I AM DONE.
>> Dana: JESSE, DO YOU THINK
THE PEOPLE OF YUMA, ARIZONA, WHO
ARE NOW HIRING PRIVATE SECURITY
TO PROTECT THEIR HOMES FROM
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS SHOULD GET
DAMAGES FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT?
OR GET REIMBURSED?
>> Jesse: THEY SHOULD, BUT
THEY WON'T, AND THAT'S A
QUESTION FOR THE LAWYER, BUT
HAROLD, IF YOU ARE GOING TO SEND
MONEY TO THE MIGRANTS DOWN SOUTH
IN THE WESTERN HEMISPHERE, THEY
ARE JUST STEALING.
YOU ARE NEVER GOING TO GET A
RETURN ON THAT INVESTMENT AND
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE JUST WANT TO
BE TREATED EQUALLY.
THEY WANT TO BE TREATED WITH
RESPECT.
IF YOU CAN BREAK INTO THE
CAPITOL ON JANUARY 6TH, THEY
WILL THROW YOU INTO SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT.
BUT IF YOU BREAK INTO SOMEONE'S
HOUSE ON THE BORDER, JOE BIDEN
WILL THROW YOU A PARTY, GIVE YOU
FREE BUS TICKETS AND WILL GIVE
YOU CASH, HE WILL GIVE YOU A
FREE PHONE.
HE WILL DO YOUR LAUNDRY.
NO ONE DOES MY LAUNDRY.
I HAVE TO GO PUT THE LITTLE
FABRIC SOFTWARE IN THERE AND
FOLD.
I HATE DOING MY OWN LAUNDRY.
>> Greg: IT'S $24.
>> Jesse: IT COSTS A LOT OF
MONEY, AND YOU HIT PAUL PELOSI
AND THE HEAD WITH A HAMMER, THAT
GUY IS AN ILLEGAL ALIEN, HE IS
NOT GETTING BAILED OUT.
HE IS NOT GETTING BAILED OUT,
BUT IF ANYBODY ELSE GETS HURT BY
AN ILLEGAL, THEY ARE GONE AND
THEY SKIP THE HEARING.
OR LIKE YOU CAN TRUST PASS IN
THE SUMMER ON THE BORDER, BUT IF
YOU TRESPASSED INTO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD, NO, NO, THEY
WILL KICK YOU RIGHT AT.
THERE IS PREGNANT MOTHERS IN
THESE BORDER TOWNS THAT DRIVE TO
THE HOSPITAL AND DELIVER THE
BABY IN THE MATERNITY WARD IS
FULL WITH ILLEGAL ALIENS
DELIVERING BABIES AND THEN I
HAVE TO PUT THEM BACK IN THE CAR
AND DRIVE TO A DIFFERENT
HOSPITAL.
WHAT IF SHE STARTS DELIVERING
THE BABY AND YOU ARE DRIVING
THROUGH THE DESERT TO THE
HOSPITAL, DO YOU THINK THAT I
COULD DELIVER A BABY IN THE
DESERT?
NOW.
I DID NOT GO TO LAMAZE CLASS,
AND THOSE THINGS ARE SLIPPERY, I
WILL D